Justice League unites DC's mightiest
superheroes in an epic battle to save
the earth from a deadly threat and the
movie also features not just one but two
cool and credits scenes yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
breaking down what's in the Justice
League post credits scenes what they
mean for the future of DC Cinematic
Universe plus some hidden easter eggs
you might have missed I'll be talking
spoilers for the end credits only not
for the plot for the end of the movie if
you want to avoid any spoilers though
tap here for my spoiler free video with
the Justice League cast at Comic Con I'm
also starting my giveaway for two
Justice League the art of the film
hardback books which are loaded with
concept art sketches and
behind-the-scenes shots from the set for
your chance to win make sure you
subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie on this video okay let's start
with the most important end credits
scene which opens in a prison there's a
guard wearing a cap with an A for arkham
asylum on it and if you recall at the
end of Batman V Superman this is where
Batman with sending Lex Luthor the guard
calls over to a bald man in a Cell who
has his back to the camera when there's
no response the guard turns the man
around revealing it's not Lex Luthor but
another man who starts laughing
maniacally the scene then transitions to
a boat arriving as an extravagant yacht
boarding the yacht we see the silhouette
of a figure that comic book fans will
instantly recognize as Deathstroke aka
Slade Wilson and he's meeting with non
other than Lex Luthor who's evidently
escaped from Arkham Deathstroke then
takes off his mask revealing his
signature eyepatch plus gray white hair
and beard Lex Luthor says that with the
Justice League having just formed their
own team of superheroes he and Slade
Wilson need to level the playing field
and form a league of their own so this
is hugely exciting because it means
we're looking at a super villain team-up
of Luther and Deathstroke plus probably
more villains by the time the Justice
League sequel comes around and there are
two likely possibilities for this super
villain League the first is the
injustice league which as its name
suggests is a kind of opposite team to
the Justice League Ezra Miller who plays
the flash has said he liked to see the
injustice league in Justice League two
although he's admitted he's not party to
DC's plans for the sequel yet
second possibility is a legion of doom
and there are some hints that suggest
this could be DC's preferred option on
TV and in the comics the Legion of Doom
has been a principal team of antagonist
to the Justice League with Lex Luthor
being a leader in many versions and
Luthor clearly seems to be the initiator
of the idea in this end credits scene
plus as a billionaire he has all the
obvious resources to spearhead such a
project most tellingly though is a tweet
in early october by the actor who plays
Deathstroke Joe Manganiello where he
posted a picture of himself wearing a
shirt with Legion of Doom on the front
in a similar style to the Justice League
title I also wonder whether the meeting
between Luthor and Deathstroke out on
the water could be a little hint to the
Hall of Doom which has been the legion
of Doom's headquarters and is often
hidden in a swamp and interestingly in
the Final Crisis comic book storyline
the Hall of Doom is offered to Lex
Luthor and his team of supervillains
just before Darkseid's invasion of Earth
incidentally Zack Snyder already teased
this post-credit scene back in September
2016 when he tweeted a photo of a
storyboard in which we can see a picture
of Deathstroke talking to what appears
to be a bald man doubtless many fans
will be very happy at the prospect of
Deathstroke coming to a DC movie in the
future but Lex Luthor was quite a
divisive character in Batman V Superman
with some fans not enjoying Jesse
Eisenberg's take on the mega maniac
super villain the post-credits scene is
obviously very short so it's hard to
judge whether Eisenberg's Luthor will
engage a wider set of fans in future
movies but the fact he's out of prison
now also means he's available as a
villain in a potential Man of Steel 2
Deathstroke aka Slade Wilson is set to
get his own solo movie in the DC movie
universe and Warner Brothers has been in
talks with the raid director Gareth
Evans to dirac the film so far we don't
have any details on whether the solo
movie might be a prequel of sorts to his
meeting with Lex Luthor in other words a
Deathstroke origin movie but it wouldn't
surprise me if it is by the way it's
possible that the bald guy in Arkham
Asylum and the end credits isn't just a
random criminal but it could be missed
as as a Batman villain and serial killer
who carves a mark into his own body
whenever he kills someone and he often
appears with a shaved head
the other end credits scene is a fun one
for fans and features of Flash Superman
race in the steam flash jokes that the
race isn't really a match so measuring
thing to which Superman quips if he wins
flashes off the team the race is a
little a marsh the discussions many fans
love to have about whether their
favorite character is faster or stronger
than someone else's favorite character
the scene doesn't really give us an
answer to this debate ending in what
looks like it's high in a similar
outcome to some of the Superman Flash
races in the comics for example in
Superman issue 199 the UN proposed a
fund raising race around the world
between the two heroes when Superman and
the flash discovered the ma'bud set of
illegal bets on the outcome of the race
though they agreed on ending it with a
tie a convenient outcome that ensured
neither set of fans ended up
disappointed and the similar scenario
happened in the flash issue 175 when
they raced around the entire Milky Way
so did the post-credits get you hyped
for Deathstroke and what do you think
about a super villain League battling
the Justice League in a sequel and if
you seen Justice League already what did
you make of the movie and how do you
think it compares to Batman V Superman
I'd love to hear what you think in the
comments below and also make sure you
subscribe for a chance to win one of
these two Justice League the art of the
film books if you're the person on
screen now then you're the winner of my
spider-man homecoming blu-ray deleted
scenes giveaway congratulations and make
sure you contact me so I can get your
details to send you the prize I've got
more Justice League videos on the way so
turn on your notifications to get those
and I'll also add links here as soon as
they're ready if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate your thumbs up and you
can check out more videos you might like
here thanks for watching and see you
next time you be gay movie lovers